et agathe kelly agathe alors je vous le
dis ce soir où on a envie de répondre à
cette question on a tous envie de savoir
parce qu'on ne sait pas pour vous
détestez mais juste avant de tenter une
médiation avant tenté de réconcilation 1
ce soir j'aimerais vous écriviez chacune
il avait une petite pancarte sur une
pancarte le premier mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit quand on vous parle de l'autre
alors allez-y
si vous ne savez pas écrire au mono dlp
pour donner assez de haine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que est ce que vous avez fini le
film super du mcri vous n'avez pas de
créer ba et ba fallait venir avec ses
affaires au bac tu seras toute seule ma
belle à est-ce qu'on a une craie et
kelly voulait pas lui prêter votre part
le volet calson la voilà vous êtes
mauvaises langues allaient alors
attention agathe ça y est vous avez
écrit premier mot qui vient à l'esprit
quand on vous dit kelly et soyez franche
d'accord si l'on va démarrer
temis avec ses beaux animaux ouais pas
ce petit on l'a kelly qu'est ce que vous
avez vu je vois pas lol ouais mais
pourquoi mais on sait que ces salles
parce que ça lui arrive d'être marrant
et vous agace
j'ai écrit mon meilleur ennemi c'est un
rite elle m'a dit
l'ofj une fois elle m'a dit qu'elle
avait toujours rêvé d'avoir une meilleur
ennemi comme dans les séries américaines
et qu'elle était ravie que je sois cette
personne là bas
est ce que quelqu'un pourrait donner un
défaut et une qualité d'agathe je parle
du coup oui bah oui j'écris ou jeu par
vous parler de leur accord un des fois
une qualité
ouais
une qualité quand elle n'est pas là ça
nous est arrivé de nous parler à aller
pouvait être rigolote d'accord
évidemment vous la trouvez drôle ah
ouais c'est vrai spectacle acheter des
places y en ait un défaut beaucoup trop
lunatique d'accord agathe qualité kelly
elle est
alors elle est
elle est marrante c'est un défi c'est
vrai elle a beaucoup d'humour et un
défaut nous n'allons rien ou tout objet
dansant à défaut un défaut peut-être un
peu et allez allez allez
non c'est l'antre des fois malhonnête la
déraison
ça commence vivalis est ce que vous avez
une question à poser à gastes que vous
n'y avez jamais posée quand est-ce que
tu pars est-ce que tu as une question à
lui poser et pareil pour agathe alors
qu'ali un tombé à gastes si vous avez la
question avant agata ce que vous en avez
allez-y l'une des deux qui peut démarrer
la garde allez-y malaisie makeli
en fait tu me détestes vraiment ah oui
ma question non c'est la vérité vraiment
et sincèrement kenny je pense que je te
déteste autant que tu me détestes bon
les filles sont terribles on a pas mal
ça commence à ressembler à quelque chose
et pourtant rien n'était fait pour que
ça marche comme ça bah décalé pourquoi
un jour tu dis bonjour et le lendemain
tu parles pas mais parce que tu l'as dit
cyrus tribune à tiques moi j'ai un
problème en fait je suis tellement j'ai
un côté très immature et très entière
c'est soit tout soit rien et j'ai
beaucoup de mal à cacher mes émotions
oui mais je ne joue rien femmes et les
routes ont rien fait ça pose là je
promets que je vais être beaucoup plus
je vais beaucoup plus prendre sur moi
afin que cela ne se ressente plus sur
mon espace de travail en tout cas parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pas lieu alors
les chéris vous allez avoir trente
secondes chacune pour donner votre
version voilà à cette tension clés nés
entre vous dites vraiment toute la
vérité
si toute la vérité kelly et agathe
on va démarrer avec agathe alors mais en
vérité il ya eu ni embrouille niklasch
les trahisons et c'est parce qu'à
l'époque en plus on se parle et on s'est
dit des choses assez personnelle et
aucune des deux n'a trahi l'autre jeudi
renault secret sont bien gardés enfin
moi je sais que j'ai confiance en kelly
et réciproquement là dessus mais en fait
c'est comme si vous seriez vous demande
pourquoi vous détestez yann barthès vous
allez me bats je sais pas parce que je
même plus je suis maintenant je vais
avoir des raisons des tests star des
fois c'est plus impalpables insondable
alors papa le pape a pu cette année
c'est pareil je n'aime pas parce que des
fois je trouve que c'est pâques elle
rigole trop fort ou que chez découvre
des trucs complètement bête c'est pas
votre fils de deux films que vous seriez
pas là dans la vraie vie c'est ya on n'a
rien en commun en fait mais il n'y a pas
de haine je dirais le provoque chez moi
aucun sentiment de haine ou de rage et
juste rien en commun
d'accord mais vous aimeriez passer du
mode et tutoré qu'elle vient de dire non
bah pas du tout du tout je peux poser
les questions au talent et hyper v ner
le basic instinct c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce serait pas j'espère que ça va se
terminer pareil au pic à glace hockey me
bats je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
elle pour une armée donné votre version
change comme si vous n'aviez pas entendu
celle d'agatha
ce qui a été à l'origine de cette
brouille embrouille the bruit moi je
suis arrivé à presles ouais donc je
pense qu elle c'était un petit peu
installé dans l'émission voilà avec les
autres chroniqueurs peut-être qu'elle
s'entendait bien avec tout le monde avec
vous vraiment avec tout le monde et
peut-être comme voyant arriver elle
s'est dit bassett fume c'est plus moi la
jolie jane de l'émission voilà ça il
peut y en avoir plusieurs prend la
pression peut-être que ça a été mal
acceptée
et pourtant au début c'est vrai qu'on
sait on a parlé et bien sûr que l'on
garde tous les deux nos secrets ya aucun
prévert écrit parce que la respecte
je la respecte quand même bien sûr et
ouais je pense que est ce que la
relation avec maxime gainey a joué pas
du tout franchement agacé parce que
c'est un peu leur chouchou
alors est-ce que modernisé wayne on n'a
aucun rapport avec vous tous voient la
mairie le chef leroy qui paradent l'a
dit mais rien à voir donc voilà je vous
dis vous êtes complètement à côté là
dessus franchement kelly dit la vérité
mais c'est la vérité et il nous arrive
même de faire des rigolades keddy a gâté
mais au contraire elles s'entendent très
bien contourner tous les trois il n'y a
pas de haine et on va parler d'une
histoire de robes ne fait pas du moins
ce qu'on va parler d'une histoire de
robes un message il ya un prix un jeu
moi je le savais pas c'est quoi cette
histoire qui lie menace mais c'est une
histoire de filles c'est une histoire
bête comme on dit c'est un truc de
séries américaines c'est que on a
chacune nos vestiaires et nos robes et
un jour à gabala préféré aller dans le
monde vestaires choisir une robe à moi
ça c'est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
ça ne passe pas on savait en fait que
vous détestez vous le savez pas pourquoi
entre filles ça se sait pas est ce
qu'une histoire de mec entre vous enfin
ce n'est vraiment pas z'êtes sûr mais
bien sûr ah non ne vous étiez pas sur
les mêmes doses pas là non non vous
n'étiez pas du tout sur les mêmes bye
bye du tout est-ce que vous avez le même
style de mec tout l'été les deux je
pense pas fait je n'aurais spécialement
pour n'a pas un style en particulier
ouais d'accord c'est à dire quoi peut-on
publierai ici